remember for pumping mics I said I was
gonna bring in some hats for you guys
yeah hell yeah yeah dude so funny
Jeff Ross very limited amount this for
Christian is for you damn I'm sorry but
I have shirts - I have fetal alcohol
syndrome which means that hat does not
fit my hand on the last hook this would
be the best goddamn it this always
happens to me in my life and it's always
embarrassing it is horrible no now I
have to do it front of Dave Attell this
sucks
now it's good put them the very last one
right god damn it did it break open
split open the last hope man black we
really got a kick out of that that would
be now snap it Jesus man this is Shark
Tank that would be your thing yeah I
have four people with fetal alcohol
syndrome
[Music]
let's watch a lot of TV I see you both
with sports oriented like hey let's go
out and throw the ball around no I did
that I did that with my friends
same as you as I got older no when I was
a kid it was very TV so I watched a lot
of TV shows that people my age are not
that aware of and Christine knows some
of them you know she knows those shows
from Nick at Nite she said but I would
watch them just late night on TV and
that would be like for the honeymooners
- Carol Burnett Show I used to watch
yeah with Tim what was his name Tim
Conway and Conway Harvey Korman yeah I
used to watch that show yeah ton taxi
his house sheis and every show with the
Q&A with the audience you know he likes
to meet her crowd the worst was when
Tracey Ullman would do the thing with
the crowd at the end and she'd go oh go
home stupid voice there's a thousand
characters and they're all an old weird
English which like that was my like you
go to school and like you can't wait to
get home to watch some TV that was just
like a neat like like really bad food
would make me sandwiches and you know I
was like in like in the South Park I was
like the fat kid and like these kids now
like they don't even need that because
they have the phone so they can like
just do whatever they want to do it like
but we had like race home dude racing
home from the bus stop I knew if I got
home at a certain time I could watch -
saved by the bells real into - Brady
Bunch's hmm Isabella you guys got rid of
cable it wouldn't matter much
yeah really would you you watch
everything on Hulu and Netflix and
everything's just on-demand using is a
crazy thing that lived through and every
year I get a new technology that I'm
willing to to believe in what isn't like
give it - I'm trying to think what next
year's is gonna be I didn't believe in
all my online payment was a big one for
me
don't call now I'm okay are you I'm not
into that either
yeah you have a flip phone yeah good
phone I don't I don't do any of that
stuff you don't nuber you know yellow
cabs
I don't what if you're not what if
you're on the road who need then I then
I guess I have to walk
good man like chai khon kaen become I'm
just walking through the dead no when I
was out in LA I was just out there and I
tell this to Nikki Glaser early because
we both were out in LA like doing shows
and like I took regular cabs it was
really weird
to like be the only guy wait like
hailing a cab like I was there too I
like solve the black dahlia murder
take me to Hollywood and Vine Superman
is linked to this murder and I can prove
it it goes all the way out to the
studios guys not our cab drivers they
are like it's like a small club like you
have to definitely it definitely there's
some kind of initiation really it's an
Armenian like card with a dove feather
like have you let out yeah like if you
borrowed a cab drivers car and showed up
they'd be like did you know do they walk
on fire and they don't know any places
outside of their little world no I - the
Melrose improv improv I was off I didn't
do her for a long time either I stay
away from that one - in justed cabs
however once you buy in the technology
it is way better it is significantly
better because you don't have to say
anything you get in he's got a map to
where you're going already
let's play a game ok ready let's try and
guess how many people in this room have
ridden on an electric scooter it's my
game obviously right away I have not so
you are not ok I'm gonna say you have
have not really I'm down 1 you're up
electric scooter no no no never never
absolutely no here's what happened yeah
you were waiting for jadeybug knob I saw
him lying around all outside and I were
I had to go I walked it every time but
it was like a half mile or so walk mhm
and then I saw Emily they look like
they're kind of fun yeah yeah look are
they're kind of fun and so I got the
whole app and loaded it up and they go
and then I got on it and you know before
I I put one foot on it and like push the
button and see what kind of does my god
yeah look at that it goes then I got on
it and it says you're supposed to kind
of kick a few times and then it'll start
catching I think I was too heavy
oh it didn't never really call it the
motor part so then I just didn't want to
be embarrassed and get off it with a
good angry likes to do so I just like
foot cranked myself the whole way there
like an idiot yeah I looked like an
asshole just Asian kids just cruise like
like - yo drifting through
everything move along the back I'm sorry
everyone
yeah I have to get to big and tall for
it clothes I got a party a big and tall
scooter when I was in Spokane it was
Halloween so right away like everyone's
costumed up but they're also on the
scooters so it's really weird to see and
they're like drunk and like going like
no helmets you know just like dressed up
as like a little mermaids going like
right into the bar like yeah wiping out
everywhere I think that's cool I'm sure
these guys have all done it
know what am i I thought I was wrong
well it's not New York really yet no no
I know it shouldn't be I really hope
they don't they should do a one-two
punch of like pot is legal and scooters
scooter good luck I mean there'll be a
thousand scooter deaths a year if it's
me or you can't hora no it's impossible
when they found out how to pop the
governor off those things and just take
them without using it I really what
about it is a weird rule that it's just
like you know drop it on the street
wherever you found who gives a
whatever we don't care what are we nerds
we really are designing jobs I talked to
a goober driver about this the other day
just about the ax and Dave Smith used to
have a pretty great joke but he used as
being on a desert island but we always
make all the jokes we talked about on
the show a lot our part in the
apocalypse what its gonna be after the
you know when we're walking dead life
and I think we have to really start
making our way to the Midwest that's
what I've decided because what skills do
we forget all the technology we have no
technology we have no electricity I
think we're in a pile of like web
designers and you know fashion
buyers like who's gonna who of us in
this building right here is gonna kill
skin
cook like dice up and cook deer
I couldn't even do the process of I
don't know if I could kill it alright
yeah that'd be real tough that's weird
in New York is known for its chefs but
yeah we have very few hunters Gordon
we're all gatherers guys you know fusion
food that's great he just let me get it
on the plane I'll give you a nice Asian
fusion deal with it's funny the people
you want as soon as the goes
haywire the people you're gonna want to
be right next to or wild Trump
supporters who everyone says they hate
you're gonna want a buddy up to that guy
real quick cuz he knows how to kill an
elk so you know that you called dumb I
know how to farm well Hillary had some
good ideas I just really I realized as a
what would your 41 year old I lack
almost all skill that doesn't involve
technology to survive did you ever go
camping real camping never no I was in
joy Skousen
you were I was to borrow me how many
badges I would say I was somewhere I was
10 I was not really remember this was
like right after the Vietnam War son
being in a uniform was really tough it's
funny like it was more of like get high
in the woods kind of scene because it
was so like there was no helicopter
parenting it was more like you know okay
you guys are out there you're camping
you know tang and all that kind of stuff
and you know making fires that you don't
need and just like having good times you
wouldn't hear from your parents or
contact them the whole time you were
gone she couldn't not at all like if
something happened you a Boy Scout camp
which did happen to me I was hit on the
head with a log that they would have to
like send a runner
skip run it down to the the fire trail
you must run I'm pretty sure the only
Boy Scout camping trip I went on was a
setup for a guy to a couple guys to
molest all of us but I just think he was
interacting to me I can only guess that
because we went to in the middle of the
woods I mean an abandoned we all slept
like in an abandoned house in the middle
of the woods it was what to the call to
cabin wasn't fair it was like a place
where crackheads would sleep
if this was in a city it was like a
boarded up weird thing that they put a
fire in the fireplace badass everyone
slept on the floor it was freezing cold
inside that's not the boys caste and I'm
- yeah that's the caravan that was the
cameraman it was the flare when I'm
telling it's what it felt like the whole
vibe was very bizarre he's just wearing
this yeah so I swear to you like
something like that that's pretty badass
no it's not wow that is cool
no it's very horrifying it's terrifying
but that's what makes it so cool look
what your fans all over the country so
let me tell you I was in LA right and I
had nothing to do so I went downtown LA
we have this thing called the death
Museum have you guys heard of no it's
pretty cool it's got like all the serial
killer stuff in it it's got like just
weird like Polaroids of like just like
weird deaths and like car accidents from
like the 60s and just like all this
crazy stuff you know the guys from the
Heaven's Gate cult they bought the bunk
beds so you can like look in at these
like dummies laying in the bunk bed so
you can like and even that's kind of so
that's so rock-and-roll whole but I said
it was kind of like Hot Topic for adults
you know it's kind of like this weird
and they're all goth people in there you
know like the goth kids of LA or in
there and I was like walking around with
the old man and I was like waiting for
one of the guys because it's go like do
you want to take me home and do that to
me kind of stuff
you face old individual razor blades
outside for all the sand you let some of
that pressure out of your thigh you'll
feel better
here's the best part here's a Dixie cup
for they go hey we gonna they had like
my head shot like they just like
downloaded and they go can you sign this
and I go you got to put it up on the
wall like a dead careers yeah right next
to Toys R Us Geoffrey is very graphic
the stuff they show ya was really it was
more than you thought it it's also like
like they had a whole tape of an autopsy
you know like you get to see like from
beginning to end I don't know who's
sitting there and then of course this
you know the CG Alan's not like all that
kind of stuff in there and they said
they have another one in New Orleans
which I assume is more uh that's all
spicy
oh you want to see how a gator gigantic
Gator head you gotta walk into the
and see all the hits all reptile death
yeah all this is serpentine everything
in here got killed or is a lizard I tell
you what I used to say that I think I
want to see those things but I really
don't know I'll tell you what the MTV
when I was spreading tonight my friend's
house he put on that tape banned from TV
and I remember the girl off by the train
I was and then there's the one
right after that is and this actually
links into the story what we wanted to
bring up for Dave but in Brazil there
was a hostage situation and the guy took
his stuff off and tried to act like a
hostage and one of the federales knew it
was him and right when he comes through
they just catch him with a
shotgun in the chest yeah you watch him
like slowly getting shot in the chest
yeah i up the suicide yeah but
there was that one it was a philadelphia
politician years ago then kill himself
on live TV era that's right yeah but I
mean when they have that in the museum
yeah but you're but the thing is I've
actually gotten almost without even
meaning to desensitize there's so much
stuff that was like I can't the first
beheading I well I think I'd be hitting
I still have a hard time with but that
first one that came out the one that
everyone saw Yahoo put in yo uh I forget
his name that I feel terrible but not
Daniel Pearl was it yeah yeah they when
they know he was a guest this
guy was a good contractor or something
the first one they killed and they
showed the video came out and it was
like you know do not why I want and I
really was one of the only things ever
when it was over I was like I wish I
didn't see that
I really but then we watched that video
everyone was getting I feel like a
weirdo we watched a video of the girl
hanging out the window of the car like
showing her tits and then like you know
I know so that it hits like a pole it's
and I can ask you is he beheaded I'm
yeah yeah it's gone you can't see if you
see like a team you know her body is
like limp and it ends right there but I
can watch that now without like grimace
almost very weird you get desensitized
you don't mean to because I might get
horrible things yeah yeah but you like
later in that like later when you go to
sleep then you then the images like
coming to your head like when you lower
your filter that's that's like well it's
just like pop in I wear
when I go into hotel rooms I do you
there it is
when you go to so she is she dead yeah
yeah when you go to sleep in hotel rooms
the word hotel rooms a lot I think Dan
you said you're all lights off TV off
right yeah if you go to bed do you go to
bed everything off yeah pretty well it
really depends on the room if it's a
suite and I'm not saying that I rate a
suite but sometimes you play Vegas and
they give you like that conference room
area that creeps me out more than when
it's I always go I just need like a
little room I don't need like that extra
like you know I'm gonna have like plan
in Ocean's eleven I don't know what that
is there having a peace treaty you guys
some other world leaders are gonna hear
tomorrow like I'm meeting with the
Legion of Doom
I went to a hotel he wants where they
had you I got a weird board like
boardroom attached and it's really funny
to eat like like a Subway sandwich look
at all this sandwich for none of my
friends but ya know if I had that room
then I'd have to keep a light on or two
just because I want to know what's going
on I'd always keep a light on I keep the
TV on with no volume weird I keep a
light on like by the front door of it
TV with no volume and I watch a cartoon
like you know like the Family Guy type
cartoons on my computer what would
happen all during all night long like
you just need that all night long just
to keep you for when I fall asleep
eventually the computer will just like
it kind of does that like are you still
watching this acknowledges I don't hear
when that happens but if I wake up for
five minutes not even if I just wake up
open my eyes and I see that it's that
screen like continue watching or leave
it off I always hit continue when it
comes back really I go back to sleep
yeah here's Dean had to learn to sleep
with you were asleep in the dark person
she had to learn it's like even at home
you have to keep a light on not a light
either you keep the TV on while you
sleep the entire time at night it goes
off eventually you know that's like
really bad for you I'm fine yeah they're
saying like for your sleep cycle it's
really bad to sleep and they think it's
my house am I gonna watch Hellraiser
yeah well that's the thing yeah I can
only watch horror movies late night
Christine falls asleep and for whatever
reason her sleeping presence is the only
thing that will save me from monsters
okay so you're very powerful in your
sleep it's why I'm telling it's very
weird
I would never watch a horror movie late
night on the road I don't never that
stops it wigs me out
I get that fear sometimes I walk a
little fast getting out of the elevator
like a club quarters hotel in San Fran
where you stay how is it windy hallways
that's there something like that when
you get off and it's just shining it's
just quiet and and empty and yours
walking just hear all you hear is your
footsteps and your bag swinging or
whatever and it's and you're like this
is haunted it has to be look at hallway
I get very wigged out and then the ice
machine goes it was haunted dude
straight up right to Vancouver have you
hope yes to move oh absolutely yeah I've
been the comedy mix I don't know what it
was I was trying to go to bed and I was
lying there and I just it sounded like a
pipe was dripping and then I walked and
then the the noise moved and it was
with me and I call the house
there's little I can I move I I'm
hearing something can I move and like
yeah sure of course and then I moved
rooms and slept great and then did they
tell you it was haunted no I never found
that out mmm kind of just ran I know I
bet you there's a lot of like people who
were into that who wouldn't want to stay
in the room cuz it's haunted that's
really weird to me when people are like
yeah no let's go to this haunted house
at state he paid like 600 bucks the
place some lady got raped and murdered
downstairs I'm good that's like that's
like a weird people travel around to
like these these sites and yeah that's a
would you take a great deal on an
apartment if like a junkie right there
no no I I'm actually like had had like
apartments where people did die and all
that kind of stuff and they just now I
have to tell you like that's part of it
like they have to tell you the record
but does it matter to you if it's
someone just died in their bed of old
age or horseback
you're okay with that but if a murder
you wouldn't know I would rather it be
someone cooler than an old aged person
yeah this guy died get these dicks out
to do it crime and marijuana
that would be good and that's a man as
much if he's haunting me that guy's a
party guy sleep in sunglasses
you